the Joe Rogan experience change the name
of the guy Mark Schultz fights good
movie though I lost I lost faith in
based on true story movies when the
dragon came out the Bruce Lee movie by
Jason Scott Lee he did he was played
Bruce Lee yeah and there was so much
[ __ ] in there oh my god filled with
[ __ ]
it's shut in the movie in the movie he
had a real fight at the Long Beach arena
he was just at in reality he was just
doing demonstrations but in the movie
they had him he did have a real fight
there and then a movie during the fight
his opponent like broke is back with the
sidekick and in the movie he was in the
hospitals heartbreaking in reality
[ __ ] his back up lifting lifting
weights he was lifting weights he was
back in the know in that fight no mostly
to death but he never had a professional
fight ever ever right ever not one fight
never no I don't think he ever competed
I don't think he had an amateur fighting
yeah I mean he fought like he had on the
streets and you know the show yeah on
the streets and he fought in a YMCA for
the right to teach non-asians kung fu in
San Francisco that'd be a flowers yeah
he had real fights he was a real fighter
but he didn't have a real professional
fight yeah he didn't have anything like
that he broke his back lifting weights
not in a professional fights was he
lifted when I saw that I thought okay I
can't trust any Hollywood movies now
based on a true story a little bit
no no well no no no no it's now it's
inspired by true events files yeah I dig
that she can't entertain stuff you can't
add stuff you can't add a gay
relationship can add a karate kick to
the back that [ __ ] you up puts you in
hospital you can't add that oh oh in in
reality he had to fight if you if he
beat this guy at a YMCA he had the right
to teach non-asians because that was an
issue back then yeah they're like why
you teaching you Americans are [ __ ] and
he's like I'll teach anybody who [ __ ] I
want so he had to fight and wasn't
see a in the movie in the movie it was
in an underground cavern with like
elders and these little spots and then
the guy [ __ ] his back up again gasps
he kicks him
yes but it's like it wasn't a weird like
Illuminati can I love that part though I
hate when they do that yeah it was all
[ __ ] can't do that about a real
watches documentary you [ __ ] that's
like when Abraham Lincoln fought the
vampires it was obvious it was a hey we
don't know maybe he killed them all
that's why we could sleep good at night
that movie she's no underrated we do
know a lot of people out there are
drinking baby blood maybe after a while
you turn in like two into like like a
vampire kind of person
[Applause]